you know your circadian clock
um is one of the most robust features of
your biology I know you can be nocturnal
or you can be diurnal we know you're
mostly nocturnal um certain times of the
year Lux but
um but they're very very few people can
get away with no sleep very few people
can get away with a chaotic sleep wake
schedule so you have to obey a 24-hour
AKA circadian uh Rhythm
um if you want to remain healthy of Mind
and Body we also have to acknowledge
that it's
aging is in linear right so um what do
you mean well I mean you the degree of
change between years 35 and 40 is not
going to be the degree of change between
40 and 45 but I will say this
I'm 48 and I feel better in every aspect
of my psychology and biology
now than I did when I was in my 20s
yeah sort of quality of of thought
um time spent
um physically I can do what I did then
which is probably says more about what I
could do then than what I can do now but
if you keep training you can continue to
get better the key is to not get injured
and I I've never trained super hard I've
trained hard but I've been cautious to
not for instance weight train more than
two days in a row I do a split which
basically three days a week and the
other day is a run take one full day off
take a week off every 12 to 16 weeks
I've not been the guy hurling the
heaviest weights or running the furthest
distance but I have been the guy who's
continuing to do it when a lot of my
friends are talking about knee injuries
hey hey hey
but of course with sport you can't
account for everything the same way you
can with Fitness and and I have to
acknowledge that you know
um unless one is power lifting you know
weight lifting and running you can get
hurt but it's not like skateboarding
where if you if you're going for you're
gonna get hurt that's just you're
landing on concrete and
um it with Jiu Jitsu like people are
trying to hurt you so that you say stop
um so with a sport it's different
um and these days I don't really do a
sport any longer
um I work out
um to stay fit I I used to
um continue to do sports but I kept
getting hurt and frankly now like a
rolled ankle
um
I may put out a little small skateboard
part in 2024 because people have been
saying we want to see the kickflip you
want to say well I'll do a heel flip
instead but okay
um uh I might put out a little part
because some of the guys that work on
our podcast are from DC I think by now I
I I should at least do it just to show
like I'm not making it up
um and I probably will but I think doing
a sport is different that's how you get
hurt
overuse and doing it an actual sport and
so you know hat tip to those do an
actual sport
and that's a difficult decision like I a
lot of people have to make I have to
make with Jiu Jitsu for example like if
you just look empirically I've trained
really hard from all my life and
grappling Sports and fighting Sports and
all this kind of stuff and I've avoided
injury for the most part and I would say
I would attribute that to
um training a lot sounds
counterintuitive but training well and
safely and correctly keeping good form
saying no and I need to say no but
training a lot and taking it seriously
now when this training is kind of a side
really a side thing I find that the
injury is uh becomes a higher and higher
probability when you're just doing it
every once in a while every once in a
while yeah that I think you said
something really important that the um
saying no I mean the times I have gotten
hurt training is when someone's like hey
let's hop on this workout together and
it becomes uh let's challenge each other
to do something outrageous
um sometimes that can be fun though I
went up to cam haines's gym and he does
these very high repetition weight
workouts that are in circuit form I was
sore for two weeks but
um I learned a lot and didn't get
injured and um and yes we ate bow hunted
elk afterwards nice but the the injury
has been a really difficult
psychological thing for me because um
so I've injured my uh my finger pinky
fingered my knee yeah your kitchen is
filled with splints splints I'm trying
to figure I'm trying to figure out
it's like if you look at last
description there's there's some really
good snacks I had some right before
um he's very good about keeping cold
drinks in the fridge
um and all the water has element in it
which is great I love that
um but then there there's a whole like
Hospital's worth of splints yeah I'm
trying I'm trying to figure out so
here's the thing you uh I think like pop
out like this right uh pinky finger I'm
trying to figure out how do I splint in
such a way that I can still program
still play guitar
but protect this kind of torque motion
that creates a huge amount of pain and
so if you have a jiu jitsu injury
Jiu-Jitsu but it's uh it's not the kind
of it's probably more like a
skateboarding style injury which is
uh it's unexpected in a silly in a silly
thing that happens in a second I didn't
break my foot doing anything important
Yeah I broke my
fifth mental stepping off a curb so it's
that's why they're called accidents
you know if you get hurt doing something
awesome that's a trophy yeah that you
have to work through it's part of your
payment to the universe
if you get hurt stepping off a curb or
you know doing something stupid
it's called a stupid accent